you think you're in an honest
relationship until you spend a year
staring at that person for 24 hours a
day and then [ __ ] comes out of your
mouth that you were not you know my wife
said to me this is how honest i got in
my house we were having sex and she was
on top of me
and she just looked down at me and she
goes
oh your face looks so stupid tonight
look that way
i agree with mom your face does
sometimes look really stupid so i asked
her because it was just us right and i
was like okay
look man we've been married a long time
is there anything you've always wanted
to do
but you've just been too scared to ask
and she was like
i know this story is not true mom's from
the south she's a southern belle she's
an angel she doesn't think anything
naughty
this whole video is just going to have
an image in my head and it's an image i
don't want great idea dad you're not
going to think i'm weird are you i go
what's the deal she goes okay all right
i've always wanted to stand behind you
and hold your penis when you pee and i
was like what
ma
what the hell man i was gonna say we're
gonna have to talk about that but you
know what i really don't want to [ __ ]
talk about it by the way has anyone done
that has anyone done that
you've done that with him that was a
quick and a very loud yes from the cross
everybody was like no and she was like
yeah me me you did it with him
okay
yo man i can tell by your face i didn't
like it either dude i don't think any
guy would like that that just seems
uncomfortable it felt like someone else
was flying the [ __ ] plane i didn't
like that [ __ ] at all that's my job i
don't need anybody else doing that nor
do i want anybody else doing that and my
wife was all willy nilly on takeoff and
landing she was like
yeah it's more like this
humble yourself
she stands behind me and she grabs my
dick and she just goes do it
what is this a nike commercial just do
it she starts to go
she goes i feel like luke skywalker i
love it
and she leans in and she whispers i am
your father
and i was like
hey don't whisper that with my dick in
your hand i don't like that this is just
terrible all those terrible thoughts she
just started to shake it does it hurt
when i do that does it hurt when i do
that how does that not hurt if i shake
it really hard if i share really hard
that doesn't hurt your penis by sharing
it like this
and then she just started to tap it
against my leg right and she goes so
when you're walking down the street
yeah don't how does that not distract
you isn't it feel like there's a little
person in your pants like yoo-hoo pay
attention to me
yoo-hoo i'm right here what do girls
think it's like to have a penis what do
you think goes on down there do it now p
do it now i can't perform under that
kind of pressure and it's not a toy look
when she's naked i'm never down by her
going hey make it talk can it say
something
can you make a voice come out of here oh
i'd love to hear a droopy dog
this here ruined droopydoc you can't
ever do it again that's your only good
impression and you've now officially
ruined it hey that really makes me mad
no well thank you guys for tuning in um
that's one of the more uncomfortable
reaction videos you'll probably see it's
just those are just images i just don't
need in my mind we'll see you on the
next one guys if you enjoy the content
uh go ahead and drop a like uh just make
sure you subscribe and make sure you hit
that notification button so that you are
aware of whenever we drop new videos uh
thank you guys for tuning in and we'll
see you on the next one have a great day
[Music]
something
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
is
[Music]